In Python 2.x, version 2.6, 2.7, and so on,
if you do integer division in Python 2.7, say, 3 divided by 2 evaluates to 1.
And 1 divided by 2 evaluates to 0.
The reason is in their wisdom the designers of Python said, well,
if you're going integer division, you probably want an integer answer,
and we'll do the best we can, and we'll have to truncate to give you the answer.
In Python 3, the designers decided, well, that's really confusing.
What you really want when you divide 3 over 2 is 1.5,
and when you divide 1 over 2 you want 0.5.
That's what Python 3 does, so it says let's change the result from an integer
to a floating point number if that's the best you can do.
Now, if you want this kind of behavior in Python 2, then you say
from the " future " with two underscores on either side of it import division.
I want that because in my cryptarithmetic problems
I really prefer this type of answer and not that type of answer.
Now I'm done, and I got a pretty concise program.
It followed by plan very nicely and easily.
I like this design of the three pieces that I've tried to divide it up into.
Look how simple the solve function is.
It just says iterate over all possible ways of filling it in, ask if it's valid,
and if it is, return. Can't get much more clear than that.
Valid is pretty simple.
Valid is almost like asking is eval f True.
If it were that simple, I would just put it in line up here,
but it's not quite that simple.
I need the try and except, and I need to catch the arithmetic error,
and then there's this little trick with the leading zero digits.
I like having a separate function for valid to break that out.
Then I like having fillin as a generator.
To make the logic of the main function simple but not to slow me down
by requiring me to generate all the possible answers at once,
the generator comes up with up the answers one at a time.
It's separating out the flow of control from the logic.
Now, am I done at this point?
Well, no, because what I have to do next is convince myself that I've got it right.